hello YouTube chest lovers and my
friends this is grunge in here imagine
that one of your opponent Lana trap from
YouTube or some other channels you try
to employ it against you you invite him
to play his trap and then you trick him
with one of your own trap which was
initially designed to means meet his
trap and you defeat him how amazing that
feeling is that is exactly of a part of
description today because we are going
to learn how to defeat the Siberian trap
now the Siberian trap is specially
designed to meet the Smith Mora gambit
let me quickly go through what exactly
the Siberian trap is so the that occurs
when white plays d4 and black responds
with the C file and here we have a Smith
Laura gambit and it's completely
acceptance by the black so black took
the pawn and it took down at the pole
and quietly capture with the knight c3
thin line runs like this so black plays
Knight c6 y place F 9 f 3 e 6 Bishop c4
and here comes the first introduction of
the Siberian trap which is going to C 7
now the bad thing about the Mora gambit
is the right piece layout are very much
predictable and especially if you are
playing a very fast game or let's say
blitz or the rapid-fire game then white
play this moves very very quickly and
that's where the Siberian traps are very
very effective and it also can be
effective if the person does not know
about this trap so let me quickly show
you what exactly it is so here white
plays Queen e2 and after black plays
Knight f6
if white foolishly Cashel over here
and the Siberian travel it comes into
the picture after this move Knight g4
and a foolish move by the white for
example s3 we have light to d4 and not
only it attacking the Queen
but it's attacking the main defender
which was guarding on the s2 and this is
almost a lost position for the white so
many players have probably feel or
defeated this kind of trap but a part of
discussion is how we can meet this strap
and if you recall at this Mordor where
black played Knight f6 now instead of
Castle there are some good players we
have analyzed this position and they
have come out with this more which is e
Phi and this is a completely in
application of the Siberian trap because
the most logical square from Knight is
to G goes to g4 which attack the pawn
and of course my need to define this
Bishop f4 and f6 by the black and at
first sight it looks like that pawn is a
goner right but here comes a deep
analysis by some of the great players
and that is Knight to d5 now the first
point is is attacking the Queen
and here the main line is of black
captured tonight but before we go to the
main line let me quickly go to the
sideline what happens if black plays
some other moves for example black can
play this move Bishop b4 check and the
ring goes to f1 and the good thing about
the white perspective is every single
line leads to the knight capture so here
the black except the night and here the
simple line runs like this so it most
likely most of the cases white will
capture their pawn and you can see it
gives the check to the black king and
not only that it Unleashed the bishop to
the screen and of course there is a only
few response available so black helped
to block this check and after we
recaptured the night we play this move
and this is very forceful so black has
to move his rook again we capture this
pawn black has to capture this pawn and
now we capture this night and you can
see it's not only attacking the Queen
and the rook but when the once the
bishop moves it gives the check to the
black king again it's a very good
position for the white so there is a one
side line if the open play Bishop b4
check
at this point black ass under boo so in
one of my game my opponent plays queen
if I check and I played King of fun and
again he captured tonight now here again
I captured the pawn let's give a check
and there are two moles here for the
black king if the King goes to d8 this
is a very bad square because after
Knight g5 it's not only threatening to
folk the King in a row but it's also
threatening a checkmate so for example
if the black take the bishop then this
leads to checkmate
so my opponent played King to f7 and I
played night check he played King takes
f6 and then I grab this night now it's
very tempting for my opponent because
this bishop and the queen is on the same
diagonal so he played d6 but after few
calculations
I took the poll with a check he
recaptured the night I played this track
he goes away I give this check and after
the rook check he blocked with this
Bishop and finally I took this pawn and
look at this position it's very very
dynamic position for the white forget
about that white is a piece down but see
right now my bishop is ready to capture
this night and
then this bishop comes into the heavy
pressure and not only that why it has
this move Queen f7 check and any
movement right can capture this bishop
and it's a very good position for the
wide again so finally what happens if
here black except the night
so black across b5 first of all right
will capture this pawn now you can see
against attacking the Queen
so only replies Knight comes in blue in
so we'll first exchange one night and
then now comes the very good move which
is queen h5 check
now if the King runs away then we have a
very good line which runs like this so
we capture this pawn in one of my game
my opponent plays this screen check I
run away
so King f1 and now there's no option
black has to capture this pawn and now
yeah it's a queen check King goes over
here c7 I capture this Bishop my
opponent play this move rook b8 but
after this capture he simply resigned
because it does not have in compensation
for this
okay ah
here the most logical reply is g6 and
the good move is this track Epsom check
and again the black has a three reply
King goes to d8 then we have this check
then after it blocks we took this Bishop
and now after few recaptures and now you
can see this f7 pawn is a video Lee
monster it can be nicely protected by
this Bishop and not only that we are
threatening to put the bishop over here
so it's a very good position for the
white okay here black can capture this
pawn by the night so if the night Rose
ab7 right now both the Queen's are
attacked but the good thing is it's
white to move and we have this move
Queen you to check and again black
response is very much full so black has
to block this check and now I will take
this and you can see it's again
attacking the Queen and the rook and
once the bishop more it's a lost finish
for the black and finally the most
interesting option is King takes f7 and
this happens one of my game and here the
simple move is Bishop takes against to
come to the check and only logical
square is king goes to get but there's a
very long sequence happens for sequence
which runs like this so we capture this
after captures captures it looks like
the rook is a goner but no black has
Intermezzo which is this Bishop check
and after we play King bee one black and
play rook a fate
and here there is a one good move which
is a three now here there can be a to
reply if my opponent played this move
which is rook F 5 then the line goes
like this so I will capture that Bishop
and once the black recapture will play
rook e1 and the most logical is d6
opening up the diagonal for the bishop
but then we can play king d2 and if the
opponent play King to d8 trying to go
away from the pin then we can capture
this rope and after we with the rook to
even it's not only attacking this pawn
but you can see the [ __ ] position of
the black pieces and especially the
weakness on the b7 and that will be a
good game for the white over here in my
game my opponent played this move he
retreated the bishop back to a fire and
I attack it again so my opponent played
Bishop b6 and now I played the this very
good move which is rook to even and my
opponent took the pawn he attacked my
rook so I played rook to e4 and my
opponent doesn't come out with any good
move order so he finally decide to go
away from the discovere check by playing
King to d8 but after Bishop d6 he played
this horrible-looking move who care fire
and it's making six now so I played this
Bishop check and my opponent was dancing
like Michael Jackson so he played king
c7 and I played this track he'd run away
I give this track I get on the way I
give this track and after he captured I
give this jack and finally when it goes
to the corner I check made him see this
kind of fun you are getting in this kind
of crappy lines and you can shock your
opponent especially if you know they are
going to play the Siberian trap I hope
you enjoy my video thank you for
watching my video feel free to comment
on my video and I will post a new video
soon bye